Neil welcome to the podcast glad to have
you on
hey
yeah perhaps you could introduce
yourself yeah so hey Anil I work on
mechanistic interpretability Research
which means I
take a notebook it's been created to a
task and I try to reverse engineer what
algorithms it's learned and like how it
does this
trying to be as faithful to the model
actually does as possible a kind of form
of digital neuroscience
I'm currently a independent researcher I
used to work at anthropic working on
their Transformer circuits work and I
generally try to work on reverse
engineering language models
so with a bunch of dalliances through
various side projects
so as I understand mechanistic
interpretability it's a pretty early
field how how young is this field would
you say
yeah let's call it mechan's Hub
mechanistic interruptability is such a
mouthful and
and I want to make Mac interp a thing uh
so the field has a snappier name anyway
so mcinturp I take the history so
deep learning as a whole has existed for
about 10 years
when
um Alex net turned out to be way better
at image classification than anything
else and this started becoming the hot
thing that's basically entirely taken
over the field of machine learning
[Music]
a field of interpretability AI
interpretability has only really been a
thing since
I don't know the history that well but
the first big paper I saw was in 2014
when people found a way to visualize
early neurons in image networks and so
they were looking at things like
edges and corners and things like that
and I would say that the at least by my
somewhat biased lights the subfield of
macinturp has been massively pioneered
by this researcher called Chris Ola who
was first involved in some work called
Deep dream at Google brain then ran the
macintop team at openai doing this
really great work on image circuits
where they reverse engineered different
things in these image models
and since around late 2021 the field has
heavily focused on Transformer language
models like chat gbt and smaller
versions of this and trying to reverse
engineer those and the field has rapidly
grown from Mostly Chris's team and
collaborators to a much larger field
with multiple professors seriously
interested maybe five industry or
non-profit orgs having teams working on
it some independent researchers like me
and hopefully it will keep growing and
we will continue this glorious
exponential trend of increasing by about
5x in the last year but pretty young
Fields yeah pretty young field why is
make interp uh useful why how would it
how would it look if if we succeeded in
this field
sure are you asking me this from uh AI
reducing AI Express perspective or just
a general like why would anyone care
about this
I I say let's start with the general and
then we can talk about the reducing AI X
risk
sure so
I think but why should anyone care about
this
my first and foremost argument is just a
kind of scientific and aesthetic
argument which is that machine learning
is becoming an increasingly important
part of the world
we're really good at giving models
complex tasks
like
someone typed in a search query to
Google what do they want what should I
show them and giving good answers and
these are capable of solving tasks that
we we just have no idea how to write a
program that can
write poetry in the way that chat TPT
can or explain jokes
and
is it just really really dissatisfied to
me this is not an acceptable state of
the world that we have computer programs
that can essentially speak English at a
human level but that we cannot write
these programs ourselves we can only
train them via this enormous soup of
data
and that's like my personal reason
um I generally think that just in a
world that is being increasingly shaped
by these systems it's just really useful
to understand what they're doing and why
for example
um lots of people are pretty concerned
about racism and sexism and algorithmic
bias and models if you can understand
how this is implemented in the model it
seems like it should be much easier to
check how well your techniques for
producing this have worked and ideally
motivate nuance
we've got recommender systems that
there are compelling arguments to doing
pretty significantly negative things in
the world I think that if we could look
inside those systems understand why they
recommended what they recommended on
like an actual algorithmic level it
would all of this would just be so much
more grounded
and we could actually have rules and
Regulation and transparency around what
was going on here
and then the cause closest to my heart
is
um AI existential safety the question of
it seems plausible we're going to be in
a world with
human level AI systems where without
getting into
arguments over the semantics and what
that actually means just systems that
are capable of doing lots of complex
tasks in the world which may be acting
towards goals and whose goals may be
different from ours
and
I think that
the people making these systems are
probably not going to want them to have
misaligned goals
but that if we can't see what the goals
are and we can't see whether the model
is actually being aligned versus doing
something deceptive or just broken and
not what we want that it's as much
harder to actually get good outcomes
here
Neil could you tell us about some
results from mechanistic
interpretability that are interesting to
you uh perhaps you could touch on
multiple results
sure all right so
um a work particularly close to my heart
is this project I worked on
um during my stint of independent
research called uh progress measures for
grocking Via mechanistic
interpretability where so crocking was
this famous mystery in deep learning
where some researchers found that if you
train a Model A small model on some
algorithmic tasks
like modular Edition the
um and you give it say half of the data
to train on and keep half of it that it
never sees to test it on it will
initially memorize it gets really good
at theater at seas and it's terrible the
data doesn't see then if you keep
training for an incredibly long time it
will suddenly grock or generalize and
learn how to do the data it hasn't seen
yet
and this is kind of wild because it just
keeps seeing the same data again and
again
and
the work I did was first to so I figured
this just has to be susceptible to Mac
and turp it's a tiny model doing an
algorithmic tops this is the kind of
thing we are good at
and reverse engineered how it did
modular Edition
where it turned out to have learned this
wild algorithm where it thought about
the numbers it was adding as rotations
around a circle and learns to compose
the rotations together in this really
weird
trick identity and Fourier transform
based way that which is ultimately very
clean and legible
and then I could look into the model as
it was training
and saw that rather than suddenly
figuring out the right solution it
actually slowly transitions from the
memorized solution to the generalized
solution
but that it could only generalize data I
hadn't seen yet when it was both capable
of generalizing and wasn't also trying
to memorize
but only when it was really good at
generalizing did it decide it didn't
need to bother memorizing
and that's a work I'm particularly proud
of because uh well it's the first
research I like probably led but also I
just feel like if macintop works we
should be able to demystify things like
this
um a totally different work that I think
is pretty exciting is
this paper called toy models of
superposition from anthropic which
people may have seen on Twitter as the
why on Earth is there a tetrahedron in
my neural network paper
where so superposition is this problem
that comes up where
so models have say n have like say a
thousand neurons in them and they want
to represent features these properties
of the inputs and often they will try to
represent
like a thousand features in there
um like a feature per neuron and there's
all very nice and reasonable but
sometimes they seem to be doing this
thing called superposition where they
actually have more than a thousand
features and they can't do a feature per
neuron and learn some weird compression
scheme
and so anthropic or like this is an
important confusing phenomena we want to
understand better let's make a toy model
that tries to simulate it
so we can study it in this kind of
metaphorical petri dish
how they found that in the toy model
they created not only did it learn to
use superposition
but that it learned these beautiful
geometric configurations
where say
if you gave it 25 features and 10
neurons to shove them into it would
sometimes learn to compress the first
five features into the first two neurons
the second pipe features into the second
two neurons Etc
and you got kind of different levels of
compression efficiency like tetrahedra
have four features in Phi in three
dimensions which is
um higher Fidelity than five and two and
models will slowly transition from
tetrahedra to the next thing along
and it was just a beautiful paper
and the final work I want to highlight
is this
work from
um
opening eye called multimodal neurons in
artificial neural networks where
so multimodal neurons in the brain are
these neurons which activate on
multiple representations of the same
thing for example a drawing of
Spider-Man the name Peter Parker and
like a picture of Spider-Man
the same neuron lights up which is kind
of fascinating so it suggests there's
some real abstraction going on
and they took this model called clip
which is part of how models like dally
the image generation model the treatment
where clip takes in both an image and a
text input
and
they thought this should probably have
abstractions because it's about image
and text
and they looked at some of the neurons
in the image half and tried to interpret
what they represented
and they found all kinds of wild neurons
including a bunch of multimodal neurons
they're like a Spider-Man neuron or a
bunch of conceptual neurons like a
teenage neuron or an anime neuron which
seemed to represent the abstract concept
of anime or teenager
um or where you got neurons for say
France that are activated on French
language the French flag but also the
bit of a map that represented France and
this was fascinating to me that this is
a thing we can find in networks and one
of my side projects would be making this
website called neuroscope which shows
the text that misactivates the features
it the neurons in a bunch of language
models
or you can just go through and look at
what kind of wild things models seem to
potentially represent
are there any concepts that you that has
been found in these um in these neural
networks that are that are entirely new
so I'm thinking that are there Concepts
that humans do not have that that could
be found found in these neural networks
unfortunately I'm not currently aware of
any examples though this feels like the
kind of thing that should be possible
I'm particularly excited about work that
looks at reverse engineering models like
Alpha zero that are superhuman at go or
chess because this is both a very kind
of algorithmic and legible domain these
systems are also clearly vastly
superhuman but also
there's been some promising work trying
to interpret them like this paper from
deepminds uh from Tom McGrath called
acquisition of Chess knowledge and Alpha
zero but they showed that if you just
took a bunch of human chess Concepts and
look for them in the model you could
just find them and further that if you
looked at when in training it had
developed these it you could compare it
to the human history of Chess knowledge
and see of what rates the model learned
things that humans learned
and also found some fascinating quirks
like phase transitions but there's a
certain point around step 30 000 when it
learns a bunch of things at the same
time but nothing superhuman this points
in the direction of there being Concepts
that are generally useful uh because the
same concepts are found by artificial
neural networks as they are found by
humans
um also your your first uh your first
example of an interesting paper where
the beginning in the beginning the the
model learns by memorization and then at
some point generalizes that sounds to me
a bit like perhaps the way that children
learn math where in the beginning you
you learn your multiplication tables and
then at a later point you understand uh
multiplication as more of an algorithm
so there are there are interesting
parallels between humans and AI systems
here
yes do you think it's easy to exaggerate
the degree to which the all these
analogies I really don't like the term
neural network for this exact reason
because it sounds so biological and
neurosciencey
but I think it's pretty plausible that
our good analogies
we need interpretability research to
understand what's going on such that we
can see whether what we're doing is
actually working we needed to create
these feedback loops between creating a
system and then seeing how the system
works and then improving the system and
if we don't understand what's going on
then it's much more difficult to
actually say that we have we have
improved because by which metric have we
improved if we don't if we don't
understand what's going on inside of
these systems
exactly and I should flag I'm extremely
biased I work in mechanistic
interpretability I like mechanistic
interpretability a lot I think it's
promising but I think there's a bunch of
other routes by which we might reach
this goal and I think the field of make
AI not to kill everyone ism is a
healthier field if it has people
pursuing a bunch of approaches including
people who aren't even doing this
because they care about AI safety
they're doing this because it's just
really fascinating and they want to
understand models better
Okay so
how promising would you say that
mechanistic interpretability is
sure so
the abstract question of how promising
I'd say
surprisingly promising in that the field
has made vastly more progress than I
thought was possible but also not very
promising in the sense of oh my God this
is such an ambitious task
and so few people work on it
um where I don't know my experience
getting to the field has been something
like well there's no way networks are
interpretable they're just a massive
super linear algebra
they're basically a kind of fancy curve
fitting algorithm or just an inscrutable
Black Box
they're not trained to be interpretable
so they have no incentive to be and then
oh hi you can actually find meaningful
interpretable neurons and image models
and meaningful uh circuits where circuit
here means kind of subset of the models
neurons and parameters that do some
tasks
and then but this is really specific to
image models because those are so
human-like we have this visual cortex
and then there's kind of worked on
language models uh on like small
language models and there's been
promising results in larger language
models but also actually being able to
meaningfully reverse engineer something
non-trivial in a model like dbt3 is this
ludicrously ambitious and hard on
anything you've done so far
so I consider it very much an open
scientific question
of whether this will actually work I
think it is a bit worth making but I do
not think it is a bet that like we
should go all in on or that it's
obviously the one true path to things
going well
in terms of
per like interesting results and reasons
for optimism
um there was this
uh paper from the anthropic
interpretability team that I was a bit
involved in called in context learning
and induction heads which I think is
probably the most compelling result I've
seen on looking at these models
actually telling us something deep about
them so
an induction head in brief is this
circuit we found in these uh two layer
attention-orly language models all right
so zooming out a bit of induction head
specifically
um the kinds of models we study in
Trader reverse engineer are Transformer
language models like Chachi PT
fundamentally it's about modeling
sequences you give it a sequence of
words and you train it to predict the
next word
like you give it a page of a book and
you ask it what comes next what comes
first on the next page of the book
and
you this is a kind of weird and
arbitrary thing you might train a model
to do
um but it's very convenient because one
this is like a pretty hard task
uh it sounds kind of easy but if you
imagine say getting the first five pages
of a book and
ending halfway through Page Six and then
predicting what comes next this is
actually kind of a sophisticated task
that implicitly involves learning a
bunch of things like
facts about the world structures of
grammar reasoning
um as people who play with chat TPT
probably know how poetry and rhyming
works
and then uh it's also really convenient
because you can just give it a massive
soup of data uh which automatically
comes with labels of what the next word
is
and so you train it to do this on a
massive massive mountain of text
and then
internally
the Transformer is all about
representing sequences which can kind of
vary in length a Transformer should work
on a sequence with like one word and a
sequence with a thousand words
and
so internally the model is made up of
these
um layers these simple functions
and Transformers are made up of
alternating
um attention and MLP layers MLP stands
for multi-layered perceptron but you
don't need to care about what that means
and
so they're modeling the sequence of
words and what they're basically trying
to do
is they take each word
and then they do some processing and
after each step you get a refined
representation of each word which is
integrated in some context and
processing from the surrounding words
so that you slowly get a better and
better understanding of what's going on
there well context the word is in plus
you can eventually predict what comes
next
and then there's there's two types of
layers which kind of do this incremental
processing
the first type is an attention layer so
at its heart because the model is a
sequence modeling thing it's doing
things in parallel on each word but
obviously you need to move information
between words
and so
attention
um is all about figuring out which other
words and their context is most relevant
to the current words
for the specific task the head is doing
um attention layers are made up of heads
which specialize into different kinds of
processing
and then it
identifies what's most relevant it
identifies
some important information there
and it copied it to the current thing
and then they're about like routing
information around perhaps an example
here could be good so say that say that
we've the model has landed on Apple and
then it's trying to predict what comes
next and say the next word in in its
training data is three
then it's looking around for other words
that might be relevant for for
predicting what comes after Apple what
would that be an every reasonable
example
clearer example is something where you
can see what kind of thing the model is
thinking so let's say you've got uh um
some text like the Eiffel Tower is
located in the city of
and
um empirically models know that Paris
comes next
and
um but the information that Paris comes
next comes from the of words like oh
clearly doesn't have enough to know
what's going on
and it turns out there are some heads
which learn to look at the word tower
um
earlier bits of the model have
integrated in the context that Tower is
part of Eiffel Tower and which have
looked up the fact that Eiffel Tower is
in Paris and then this heads moves that
from the tower bit to the other bit
and
uses that to Output Paris comes next
and actually the same heads will do
things do this for things like the
Coliseum is located in or the python
line is located in
and yeah you often get heads for
grammatical structures like look at the
first word in the sentence look at the
subject of the current sentence Etc
and so these these induction heads uh
are that's the impressive thing that's
been reverse engineered within
mechanistic interpretability so far
yes so induction heads are part of an
attention layer
um where the attentional errors built up
over these heads is that can kind of be
thought of as independently and because
it's an attention layer this is the
model doing something sophisticated with
finding relevant information and moving
it around
and the task being done
is
so
a fact about text is it often contains
repeated text
for example
um
if I see the word Michael it's pretty
hard to figure what comes next it's
probably some famous celebrity like
Michael Jackson Michael Jordan whatever
but it's hard to know exactly which
but if in the past
uh the text Michael Jackson appeared
then it's pretty likely that Jackson
comes next
and so a pretty great algorithm a model
can learn is okay
let's look for
um let's look for a word that came after
Michael in the past
and then let's move the information from
that word to where I currently am so I
predict that that word comes next
whatever that is
and
um we reverse engineered these things
called induction heads which Implement
that
and it's worth noting this isn't just
the model memorizing something like
Jackson often comes often comes after
Michael if Michael Jackson came up in
the past this comes next it's actually
just like an actual algorithm that is
run on any inputs
you can just give it some random
gibberish text
that's randomly generated then just copy
and paste that and then run the model
and it will predict that the copied and
pasted text it will predict the copy and
paste a text really well even though
it's never seen anything like that
before
so it's a general algorithm it's not as
it's not a set of fixed rules
um involving specific words
it's it's a general algorithm that can
work on arbitrary words but which does
this very specific task
yeah like it's not a lookup table but
it's also not like intelligence in any
meaningful sense
but I can see how reverse engineering
something like that is actually
impressive because now we're beginning
to understand what's going on inside of
these previously entirely black box
systems that just predict the next word
in the text
yes so I think that reverse engineering
induction heads is like cool though
Probably sounds a lot easier than
actually is from the outside but they're
not the reason that I raised the
induction heads paper
um so we actually reverse engineered
induction heads in this earlier paper
called a mathematical framework for
Transformer circuits and
um I feel like I shouldn't be saying we
uh this paper was written by
um Catherine Olson Nelson elhaj Chris
Ola and the rest of anthropic and I was
somewhat involved but they get a large
amount of the credit for doing great
pioneering work in this fields
this is my work but
yeah so these induction heads we found
them by looking at these tiny two-layer
attentionally models and then we
um looks at larger models
and it turns out that not only do all
models that people have looked at have
these heads
um up to about 13 billion parameters
um since leaving I actually had a fun
side project of looking at all the open
source models I could find and I found
them in about the 41 models I checked
all of them that were big enough to have
induction heads had them
and
not only do they appear everywhere they
also all appear in this sudden what we
call a phase transition where so as
you're training the model if you just
keep checking does it have induction
heads does this have induction heads
there's this narrow band of training
um between about how five to ten percent
of the way through training
um exact numbers vary but that's kind of
the idea
um the model goes from no induction
heads to basically fully formed
induction heads
and this is enough of a big deal but if
you look at the like uh loss curve which
is the jargon for how good the model is
at its task there's this visible bump
where the model is smoothly getting
better and it briefly gets better much
faster and then returns to its previous
level of smoothly getting better when
these induction heads fall
so that's wild then the next totally
wild thing about induction heads is that
they're really important for this thing
models can do called in context learning
so a
General facts about language models
that are trained Public's world is that
the more previous words you give them
the better they are
which is kind of intuitive if you are a
predict what comes next in the sentence
the cat said on the mat
um like what comes after
um on the in on thee if you just have
the it's really hard if you've got only
it to be easier if you've got the cat
sat on thee it's like way easier
but it's not obvious that if you add
more than 100 words it really matters
and in fact older models weren't that
good at using words more than 100 words
back
and it's kind of not obvious how you to
do this though clearly it should be
possible for example if I'm reading a
book the chapter heading is probably
relevant to figuring out what comes next
or like if I'm reading an article the
introduction is pretty relevant but it's
definitely a weird thing that models can
do this
and it turns out that induction heads
are a really big part of how they're
good at this
where
models that are capable of forming
induction heads are much better at this
thing of tracking long-range
dependencies in text
the ability of models to do this
perfectly coincides with the dramatic
bit where they're where they're learned
and
when we did things like tweaking a model
too small to have induction heads with
this hard-coded thing that made
induction heads more natural to form
that model got much better at tracking
how to use text fallback to predict the
next thing
and we even found some heads that seem
to do more complicated things like
translation where give it a text in
English give the text in French and it
looks at the word in English that came
after the corresponding word in French
these these also seem to be based on
adduction heads these induction heads
they they pop up in many different
neural networks in in many of the neural
networks that you've checked at a
certain size is this is this perhaps
analogous to how say eyes have evolved
in in different species and underwater
and on land and so on because maybe
induction heads are are very generally
useful for language models
yeah
um I think that's a pretty good analogy
I
that's actually a pretty great analogy I
think one thing worth drawing out from
that analogy is that there's two big
components to what kind of things a
model might an organism might learn
there's what is the environment it's in
what's useful and that's kind of what
constraints does it have and what's
natural
and
light light is there light is useful
understanding your environment is
important so eyes are valuable and the
same kind of underlying biology
presumably incentivizes eyes though I'm
not a biologist so I don't actually know
how much eyes implemented in the same
way or not
and
I think the analogy from biology to AI
can be a bit overdone but this
underlying principle of repeated text
happens a lot and it's useful to notice
and induction heads are a very natural
thing from model to express that's kind
of efficient in the same way that I know
walking on legs is more efficient than
growing your own wheels even if probably
we could figure that out biology could
figure that out if it really had to all
right so say induction heads are an
example of a way in which we can
understand what's going on in inside of
these uh neural networks I would like us
to to Pivot a bit to talk about how does
this line of research help make us safer
so you you mentioned that that your
largest motivation for working or
perhaps say at least one of your
motivations for working on this is to
help reduce AI risk so it
how how do you see mechanistic
interpretability helping there
definitely is only one of my motivations
I generally think of my life as
having kind of multiple different
categories of motivation there's the
high level abstract zoom in every few
months and think about my life goals and
meaning where okay I think that human
level AIS I think that's probably gonna
happen and plausibly might go badly and
I want to be doing things that address
this because making the world a better
place is a deeply important value to me
but also on a day-to-day basis that's
like not the kind of thing I can really
draw excitement from
and things like oh my God this is so fun
I get to stare at an alien organism all
day and probe's brain for how it works
or huh lots of people around me are
really smart and excited about my work
and think I'm really cool for doing it
is another thing that appeals to the
kind of monkey inside my brain
and part of how I try to set my life is
to align these various different things
but by default point the same way to
align with my abstract high level
actually what matters to me but really
hard to feel and practice
I'm
very concerned about models being
deceptive and in particular models being
deceptive in a way that
hard to notice
where
the model realizes it's being trained it
realizes it's in its interests for its
human operators to think it's doing what
they want and being aligned and
Performing well
and so it learns to fake doing that
and if it's competent which the models
I'm scared about are then
it will just do this well it will do
this in a way that's as close as it can
get
A system that genuinely can will do and
fundamentally when there are multiple
Solutions inside a model that both have
the same outputs
one of the obvious things to do is to
open up the black box of the model look
inside and try to poke around at what's
going on
and
this is one of the ways I think
mechanism interpretability is likely to
be pretty promising in particular I'm
really excited about there being better
feedback loops people trying to align
these systems where especially as you
get closer to the worlds which are
actually dangerous
where we might have systems that are
capable enough to do damage and also
capable enough to realize they might
want to do damage I think that having
really good feedback on how well the
alignment techniques work
in a way that is not
tied up with things like
um the model is making mistakes
and which can ideally be as fine grains
and mechanistic as possible this is like
a pretty valuable thing to exist
though I also just have a skepticism of
careful elaborate arguments in general
and think that anyone trying to reason
about a complex problem like AI safety
should share the skepticism
and I think for me
obviously if we understand the uh
terrifying black boxes you might be
massively influencing the world it is
more likely to get better for Humanity
I think that kind of very simple
argument satisfies a different part of
me yeah I I can see how that argument is
is powerful so
um there's a question I have about
um
mechanistic interpretability we might
this might help us understand what's
going on inside of these black box
systems right but if we if we discover
that something we do not like is going
on is there a part of mechanistic
interpretability that helps us control
the system or steer the system in a
different way or is that where you
imagine another approach in within AI
safety takes over so it's mechanistic
interpretability mostly about detecting
bad behavior and not about actually
steering or controlling AI systems in
the right direction
so
in my personal conception mechanistic
interpretability is about reverse
engineering a trained system rather than
about intervening on that system to
change what it does
I
think that it's easy to get into
semantics here where
I know
um maybe if you're a doctor you refer to
your insta your instruments as like a
very different part of medicine as like
the actually cutting people open and
making them better but these are clearly
highly related things and better
instruments enable better medication
um and better surgery techniques and I
also think it's kind of healthy for
mechanistic interpretability to try to
get feedback on kind of actually do
things
um there's this a great paper called
Rome from David bow and Kevin Kevin Meng
where they did some work to try to track
down which bits of a model contain
factual knowledge like the Eiffel Towers
in Paris but then which also used this
to
but then of the focus of the paper was
on this memory editing technique where
they change it so the model thinks the
Eiffel Tower is actually in Rome and
they've got some pretty impressive
results like if you ask it something
like the
um can you give me directions to the
Eiffel Tower it will direct you to its
Italian Railway stations rather than
French Railway stations
um and it's kind of wild though I also
think that the paper is kind of flawed
in some ways and there's been some
recent interesting criticism
um but I think I'm pretty excited about
that kind of attempt where if we really
understand how models work then we sh
these kind of things are should be much
easier because to me a lot of the field
of AI is kind of Blanding around in the
dark
and I mean one concerning implication of
that statement is that if we really
understand the system we should be able
to make better ones faster and in my
opinion even I want to live in a world
with like safe underlined powerful
systems one day I would like I feel like
the making them better is vastly
outstripping the understanding them and
making them safer and I want the
relative speed to be as great as
possible on the safest side so so Neil I
have a kind of uh a weird question here
so what I'm what I could be worried
about is say that you do some
mechanistic interpretability research
and then it's it's published online in a
paper or say it's written up in a blog
post and this then becomes part of the
training set for a future language model
could the research you're doing uh now
help future language models receive us
um because it understands how we're
trying to interpret it
uh uh yes
there are totally worlds where that
happens and it does seem like this is
not on my list of things I am concerned
about in the short term or even things
that are high my list of ways I think
that doing my research could be harmful
but definitely could happen uh one idea
which I've seen being popular on the
11th Forum that I find very fun is uh
there's
uh there's this
um string that the people who made big
bench which is this new big set of
benchmarks and metrics we use as test
language models mate where they have
this string they want to put in
documents that contain like the answers
to these questions such that future
language models can just be when you get
the data for future language models you
can just say don't include things with
this string
and there's a very fun idea I've just
put this in like all alignment posts so
we don't tip off them all
um but
so to me this kind of links into the
more interesting question of if you know
that someone is trying to read your mind
can you out think them
and my personal guess is that it is at
the very least significantly harder for
a model to out think a mind reader than
is for the model to deceive an operator
one of the main reasons I believe this
is I think that getting better at
something is fundamentally about getting
feedback and models are trained to get
lots and lots of feedback on their
outputs but models
are not trained to get lots of feedback
on their internals and how much a mind
reader can see them
um note that this argument does break if
people start doing things like
training on an interpretability inspired
metric
or giving feedback via it which I think
is a
thing that I am extremely cautious about
recommending anyone does for this exact
reason
and having technique so robust they
can't be broken is much much harder
I
yeah I think that like I don't know how
I would think my thoughts such that a
digital neuroscientist could read this
and like not see it
I think there's a couple of ideas people
have flirted with me that kind of makes
sense like
spend a bit of time thinking about what
intentions I'm forming and why and then
spend most of my time just acting on
these cached intentions without dwelling
on how I came up with them is one tactic
another tactic would just be thinking
like really weird and convoluted ways
and keep away from the dangerous
thoughts
and I can imagine some of these working
especially the model has some external
memory it can store these cached
intentions in in a way that's kind of
divorced from how they were generated we
should flag that all of this is is very
speculative and it is not your main
concern yes yes this is very much on my
list of fun things I might speculate
about with friends at 1am
rather than a thing that is actually a
thing about doing day-to-day research
okay let's dig into some of what I could
see as being problems with a mechanistic
interpretability as a research Paradigm
so I think the main worry I have is just
that mechanistic interpretability is not
fast enough so however frame this is to
say that when we learn when we get
actual feedback from the systems that
were cutting edge two years ago there
are now new systems and we have not been
fast enough to implement the learnings
in the new systems so in a sense you're
always playing catch up or at least
that's that's my fear
um what do you think that's that's a
that's a real worry
so this definitely is a real worry
I will point out that I would argue that
the field of mechanistic
interpretability of language models
didn't even exist two years ago
and all existing workers on image models
such that I'm
not I feel less bad about that one
um but I do think this is an important
point
and
what so there's
a couple of underlying questions here
there's
are we just capable of doing this at all
maybe we could do gpt3 given two years
but then if gpd4 is 10 times bigger it
would take us 20 years and that's not
the same
um but then there's just questions like
are we just gonna kind of always going
to be scrapping our previous work or can
we be building a field or like building
upon our previous work even as the exact
Focus changes
and I'm
reasonably optimistic about the building
on our progress one
I think that
a bunch of our insights and conceptual
Frameworks from image models transverts
though definitely imperfectly and less
well than I'd have hoped and there were
lots of weird things about Transformers
for example image models don't have
attention layers
and a bunch of the work has focused on
understanding what's up with attention
layers
and
so that's a category of concern
I think on the
will the problem of scale
can we actually interpret these
humongous models even if we can
interpret a smaller model
I'm kind of unsure
I
am excited about things that try to take
insights from mcinturp and scale them
and automate them
and I think that one kind of speculative
dream might be the
even if we know how we would inter
reverse engineer gpd4 given 20 years
before we get to the really scary
systems we'll hopefully have systems
that are kind of near human and can take
over a lot of cognitive work and if we
could have these systems try to help us
um and just do this 20 years of work in
weeks instead that seems in some sense
like a massive win
that could actually scale
but
yeah I think one thing I will say that's
maybe one of my more controversial
opinions is that
I think that the field of interpreting
AI is much much more bottlenecked by
really rigorous true beliefs about
networks than it is by good ideas for
things that would scale and would
actually generalize to larger models
and I think that it's just very hard to
tell which of these days are good
which of the days have subtle flaws
and I feel like just doing work to find
even some cherry-picked thing like
induction heads that we then try to
really deeply understand
or trying to discover some more of the
underlying principles behind the kinds
of algorithms the models learn and the
kinds of ways they express things even
if the exact details don't generalize
just seems like it should enable all
further things to do with understanding
these models
because at the moment it feels like
we're floundering in the dark
so if we imagine that we have AIS
helping us interpret other AIS so health
so AI is helping us understand what's
going on inside of other neural networks
couldn't this in a sense uh lead us back
to where we started because maybe the
way that that one AI is being
interpreted by another is perfectly
understandable to to the entire to the
AI That's doing the interpreting but
perhaps it's it's an inefficiency to try
to translate it into something that's
that's understandable by humans perhaps
uh
an AI trained to interpret another AI
could skip the the step of producing
something that's that's understandable
by humans and thereby work faster
perhaps it could out-compete systems
that try to translate to Human
I know if I quite followed the question
is what you're asking if we try to train
systems to interpret more complex
systems maybe those would be too slow
and inefficient such that a system
that's not trying to translate this to
human ears is just much more capable
exactly yeah so imagine that we have a
system that an AI That's interpreting
another Ai and we have two of such
system we have one system that delivers
something that's understandable by
humans and we have another system that
just delivers red or green let's say so
just thumbs up or thumbs down without
giving us actual information about
what's what's uh what's going on it just
says this this uh this system is doing
what you want it to do could you could
you see a world in which the system that
that gives us very little information
but just gives us a thumb up or a thumb
down would out-compete the system that
that tries to do the hard work of
translating a neural network into
something that's humanly understandable
so to me out competes kind of seems like
the wrong framing
I don't think that
the question is not if you had two
competing auditing companies one of whom
did the red green thing one of whom did
the sophisticated thing which then would
make more money
if we end up in a world where it's
possible to make the extremely expensive
sophisticated thing that translates it
into human ears that's just that's a
massive win
like
um pharmaceutical companies spend
billions of dollars making sure their
products are safe when YOLO put it on
the market and don't check is much
cheaper but you know we have regulation
that make it something you need to do
the really hard expensive thing that's
better at making things safer
and I'm like really not that concerned
about it will just be too inefficient or
too expensive
I'm much more concerned about a we won't
be able to do it
B it will be so prohibitively expensive
or slow that it's not even possible to
do practically you don't even know how
to do it in theory and
finally that it's just not reliable we
can't trust this system and we just get
lost in the nested chains of more and
more sophisticated systems
and on the specific point of
practicalities and kind of competition I
think one thing which is easy to
overlook here is that mechanistic
interpretability is not necessarily
about auditing every single action a
system takes
it's much more about
taking the system and trying to
understand it
clinical trials are maybe a good analogy
in this context where it's not like you
watch a patient as you give them them
it's not like you when you deploy a drug
in the world you watch every patient as
they take it you study the drug in this
clinical context that's close to the
real world is you can make it ideally by
just giving it to people and then see
what happens and get data and this can
be more this can be expensive in a way
that watching everyone who takes a code
vaccine is just completely impractical
and models even better because there is
just a long but finite list of numbers
the parameters that just Define the
model
and if we can just study this do a bunch
of running a model on inputs but
fundamentally just understand what it
represents
then I think that questions about
competitiveness just matter a lot less
there
but you think that mechanistic
interpretability will have to involve uh
AIS interpreting other AIS at some point
for it to scale to bigger systems I
think it is plausible but this is a
thing that happens
and it is plausible that the most
practical path to meaningfully
understanding like really complicated
systems is via using
less dangerous AI assistance I do not
think this is an important thing in the
near-term future of the fields
I do not think this is even necessary
before we could reverse engineer a human
level system
at least enough to figure out whether
it's safe
and this is not at all what I am
personally working on this is very much
in the speculative what I think could
happen I think in particular if we're
trying to figure out how we could align
a vastly vastly superhuman system I
struggle to imagine it really being
doable to perfectly reverse engineer by
humans
though I think that
fully reverse engineering is not on the
critical path from where we are now to
having safe AI just the ability to look
does this have internal internally
represented goals and if so what are the
goals or is this being deceptive just
scenes significantly easier yeah that's
a great way to frame it okay so I I read
one objection to the whole mechanistic
interpretability uh Paradigm or um
research field which is that uh when
you're when you're trying to interpret a
neural network you you cannot unders you
cannot from interpreting the network
itself understand how the system will
react in different environments so
imagine that you cannot get information
about how the system will react in in a
diverse set of environments and so
therefore there's a there's a fundam
fundamental limit to how much you can
get out of interpreting these networks
do you think that's a reasonable
objection
my off the cuff answer is no
um in particular to me one of the things
that's distinctive about mechanism and
reverse engineering the system is that
you you're understanding the algorithms
the model employs
and if you actually understand an
algorithm you should be able to predict
how it generalizes
you should be able to come up with
adversarial examples that will trip the
system up using your understanding you
should be able to predict what happens
on weird settings uh induction heads are
a good example where understanding them
let us predict that models could if
given complete random gibberish text
predicts repeated subsets of that and
they can
and
I'm unconvinced by that criticism I do
think there's some truth to it in that
it's very easy to impose your own
preconceptions on what Behavior you
should look for
what kinds of inputs you give it such
that you see what lights up and how you
focus on things
and I think in particular if you aren't
trying to fully reverse engineer the
system but are just trying to localize
the bits that matter most the criticism
has more teeth to me
but in my eyes macintop is one of the
more promising things that isn't
susceptible to that criticism
because we're trying to understand what
algorithm underlies the network itself
which is kind of understanding a more
General feature of of a neural network
yes
and I think there's other techniques and
approaches that also seem pretty
valuable here
there's the area of adversarial training
and adversarial robustness where you get
an adversary like a human rater or
another AI to generate examples trying
trying to throw off the system
and adversarial examples are a good
example of this the pictures listeners
might have seen where you have a
Panda you had a bunch of random noise
and it thinks it's definitely a wombat
or something even though to our eyes it
looks just like exactly like a panda and
they're just imperceptibly changed a
couple of pixels
and
yeah one field is about trying to find
the inputs that almost trip up the model
that are at least like what it's
expecting and that's another angle to
figuring out what it does in weird
contexts
but I'm honestly not really aware of
many others that I think that's
promising as macintopian
okay so actually you think this
objection applies the least to make
interpret compared to other other
approaches I don't like using
superlatives but kind of
and to be clear I think it does apply I
just think it applies a lot less
yeah
all right so let's say that people have
been listening to this and they are now
excited about Mac and serve they want to
help contribute to this field what would
be the best ways to get into this what
what should which papers or books or
video series should you should you read
should you go to hackathons how would
you go about getting into the field
sure so actually one of my side projects
for the last couple of months has been
trying to make this dramatically easier
and I have this post called concrete
steps to get started and mechanistic
interpretability which you can find if
you go to
neilnanta.io getting Dash started
and
this tries to give a pretty concrete
guide to what I think you should do if
you actually want to learn about the
field and potentially do research and
tries to collate a lot of the other
resources I've made and other things I
think are useful and good for this
um generally I think one of the really
great things about macinturp is that one
there's lots of important work to be
done on Tiny systems that can fit on a
free Google collab notebook in your
browser rather than needing some
expensive supercomputer
and which
you can just play around with and get
fast feedback within minutes especially
using some of the demos iron
collaborators have made where you can
just
play around with a model by running
existing code
and I would recommend people just like
go and screw around with
the various educational materials read
some of the papers recommended
um the people who want to take more in I
have the sequence that I'm pretty
satisfied with called 200 concrete open
problems and mechanistic
interpretability
where I try to both just like lay out a
map of the fields what I think are the
interesting sub areas big open questions
how I think about doing research in
those traps pitfalls tips but also just
a long list of concrete problems I would
be excited for someone to go and work on
would this be would this be the best
best approach say that a listener has a
general background in computer science
and is interested in this should is the
best way to to jump into one of these
200 problems and try to solve it and
then fail and then you know get feedback
from from trying to solve an actual
problem or would you rather have a a
more expanded base of theory by reading
some papers and how would you how would
you start
I personally think that most people I
see getting into the fields spend way
too long reading papers and trying to
build a broad base and none of the time
just doing things
and I think that building a broad base
is important but I think that the best
way to build the bases by doing things
failing
noticing what you're stuck at and using
this to ground your learning
and I think that going back once you've
gotten your hands dirty and going and
just like going on a learning binge and
trying to fill in a bunch of the holes
in your knowledge is like solidly
worthwhile
and I think there's a learning style
which just prefers reading a bunch of
papers am I getting started guide also
tries to give some concrete advice for
that
but code fast code early try to build
practical knowledge as well as theory is
some of the most common advice I get to
people trying to get into the fields
and again one of the things that's
really nice about macintop is there's
lots of small bite-sized problems
I tried to rank the problems my sequence
by difficulty and there's a rank for I
think someone who's new to the field
could like probably get a good amount of
traction on this in like a week or two
and I think they're just trying to do
something is one of the best ways to get
grounding and get started
fantastic perfect